there's this one lake in central america
that if you look closely enough you're
gonna see the tops of trees in the lake
and these these are not islands these
are hilltops
this all used to be a dense jungle not a
lake but then they built dams and all
sorts of infrastructure to flood this
forest all in the name of solving a
centuries-old puzzle which was how do we
make it faster and easier to travel
between here and here even in spite of
the fact that you have two massive
continents blocking any waterway but
there was hope if you look down here at
this one thin stretch of land here it's
only 80 kilometers across and it looks
so easy to just cut a waterway into it
no turns out that puzzle was not easy
this little 80 kilometer strip of land
proved to be really hard to cut through
but as long as international trade
continued to grow there continue to be
great powers looking for new waterways
to shorten their routes and to increase
their power for whoever controls the
water has the power and these great
powers always focused on this narrow
stretch of land from the spanish in the
14th century to the scottish in the 15th
but then the most earnest and serious
attempt was in 1880 when this guy a
french engineer ferdinand villacep shows
up and is like hey i got this he had
just completed another big
world-changing canal over here he was
feeling very confident and he's like yep
i'm your guy let's build another canal
it'll be easy we'll just dig down to sea
level and reroute the river like we did
in egypt for the suez canal and it'll be
great and i'll be famous but listen
egypt is a flat desert and panama is not
these mountains that you want to dig
through are well above sea level so if
you want to dig down to sea level to
make a flat canal it's not going to be
easy meanwhile another french engineer
comes to dilusep and he's like dude this
isn't gonna work it's way too much
digging instead of bringing the
mountains down to sea level what you
need to do is bring the sea up to the
mountains and in a moment of
collaborative creativity de la sept
admits that he was wrong and begins
construction based on the new plans and
then he promotes this guy as the head of
engineer and says great idea no though
this up was like bring the ocean up to
the mountains that sounds stupid screw
you i'm the famous one the canal is
going to be at sea level just like we
did with the suez canal so the french
start digging well actually it wasn't
the french it was a ton of poorly paid
migrant workers who were doing the
digging hacking away at the jungle with
machetes and then digging by hand with
pickaxes in sweltering heat knee deep in
sitting water which is heaven for you
guessed it disease infested mosquitoes
which is terrible news but luckily
dilicep the engineer was always there in
the trenches with his workers wielding a
pickaxe alongside his people yeah no of
course he wasn't he was just hanging out
in france only visiting panama twice
over the course of seven years to just
like check in on the project and what he
realized when he showed up seven years
into this digging is that things were
going horribly people were dying like 40
or 50 a day all in all 20 000 workers
died trying to dig this canal thousands
died from disease and accidents and we
will never know their names and it's not
just that people are dying it's that the
digging isn't working either they would
do a bunch of digging one day and then
the next day the rain would bring in all
of the mud that they just dug back into
the canal so de la sept shows up
realizes this is happening is like this
is not working is there another way to
dig this canal and then he has a
flashback to seven years earlier bring
the sea up to the mountains and he's
like oh yeah that was actually a really
good idea my bad we actually are gonna
do that other plan instead but no it was
too late the investors were done they
had lost way too much money 20 000
people were dead malaria and yellow
fever were rampant this was a failed
project so the company that owned all of
this work had to abandon it and leave it
unfinished in 1889. everyone gave up and
left except for one of the top engineers
on the project this guy i'm just gonna
call him phillipe because after
researching him for many days i now feel
like i'm on a first name basis with him
and by the way he becomes a giant part
of this story starting now so felipe was
this french engineer and businessman and
he was obsessed with the canal he also
had a huge financial stake in the
project and where some investors would
say darn too bad we invested in a bad
bet let's move on felipe was like no i
will do whatever it takes to make sure
that this is not a failure and what
happens next is one of the most insane
things i have ever researched in my
entire life so buckle up the window
okay so let's get some context really
quick it's like 1900 at this point the
us is really starting to like get a
handle on this whole imperialism thing
that they've been doing they just
fabricated a war with spain which led
them to conquer the philippines guam and
puerto rico they just overthrown
hawaii's government they annexed wake
island and american samoa they're like
dude this overseas empire thing is kind
of working out for us the president at
the time was teddy roosevelt who we've
seen in previous episodes and teddy is
looking around this region that the u.s
is increasingly taking over and he sees
an opportunity to dramatically increase
the naval power of the united states if
they could just unite the atlantic and
the pacific it's time to build a canal
says teddy so of course they looked
somewhere in central america and the
original plan that the u.s wanted to
pursue was to build a canal not in
panama but here in nicaragua it wasn't
the shortest stretch of land in this
area but there was a huge lake here
which would cut down on the digging and
it just made a lot of sense so they
started doing surveys and making plans
to build a canal in nicaragua meanwhile
philippe the frenchman is still down
here at his failed project and he's seen
the us become interested in the canal
and he's like this is my moment of
vindication so he goes to the u.s
congress and he's like hey guys i know
you're looking at nicaragua you've been
doing all this site planning and surveys
and stuff but guess what right next to
this proposed site for your canal there
are volcanoes big scary belching
volcanoes and one of them just erupted
around here sort of next to your site
nicaragua even had a postage stamp that
featured one of these nearby volcanoes
erupting so the frenchman goes around to
the u.s senators and distributes this
postage stamp and says look scary
volcanoes in nicaragua don't build your
canal here or they'll be destroyed by
lava or something and guess what it
totally worked the u.s senate got cold
feet about their nicaragua canal plan
and they're like
we're not going to do this anymore let's
find another place to build it and
felipe is like oh my gosh i can't
believe that just worked
stamps with volcanoes he's like all
giddy and he's like hmm i wonder where
there would be a good place to build a
canal oh wait a minute why not panama we
the french already did a ton of work to
get you started why don't you just pick
up where we left off we'll sell you all
of our gear all of our stuff it'll be a
great deal and the us is like but isn't
panama a part of colombia and yes indeed
at the time panama was actually a part
of colombia it was not an independent
country so the united states congress is
like okay listen philippe we will buy
you out of your canal project that you
clearly failed on but we will only do it
if we can get approval from colombia who
literally owns this land and felipe is
secretly like ugh there's no way that
colombia is going to go for this they're
going to reject the plan and then the
u.s is going to back out and i'm going
to lose all my money and i have to make
this happen felipe was very serious
about this canal so this is where
philippe starts to get really conniving
to pull out all the stops to get the
canal built so he goes to the people who
live in the region of columbia called
panama and he says hey guys i know
you've sort of been wanting to be
independent from colombia for a long
time bogota is so far away they don't
care about you you could be your own
country what if i a french engineer
could guarantee your independence
without a bloody war just leave the
details to me make me your ambassador
and i will make this happen and the
panamanians are like but dude you're
french and he's like yeah yeah but
you're colombian so why don't we team up
in the name of creating panama a new
country and they were like okay fine
felipe you're our representative our
ambassador now just give us the signal
when we should rise up for our
independence but you promised to make
sure that colombia is not going to come
in and quell our uprising and felipe's
like yeah yeah i'll take care of it
okay before we keep going with the story
i want to tell you about today's sponsor
policy genius about a month ago i signed
up for life insurance something i knew
nothing about for a very long time until
i did and looked into it and realized
that be a responsible adult i should
probably have life insurance it's
something that's not fun to think about
but is absolutely something that feels
good to have once you have it policy
genius is very simple takes a few
minutes to sign up and makes it easy to
compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers all in one place you could save
50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius you
could have life insurance in less than a
week that's what happened to me i didn't
even have to go to like a doctor's
office like one of the options was to
just do a medical exam over the phone
and i was like yes please it was a
simple phone call the policy genius team
they took care of all the paperwork they
did all the complicated stuff that i
would no have no time to do and before
you know it i have a life insurance
policy so go to policygenius.com johnny
harris where you can learn about
different policies and which one fits
your need and then when you're ready to
apply the policy genius team handles
everything after that for no extra cost
there's no extra fees policy genius
doesn't sell your information which is
like thank you policy genius for that
overall this is the best way to compare
quotes for life insurance and to get the
best deal that fits for you again i
literally just did this a month ago and
it really was smooth and easy and i
sleep better at night knowing that i
have a policy so thank you policy genius
for sponsoring this video so for
supporting my work and my channel that
link will be in my description now let's
get back to the panama canal so felipe
is now the ambassador of the panamanians
who are not a country yet but he's still
hoping that maybe the colombians will
approve the plan felipe sort of has this
in his back pocket this deal that he
just made with the panamanians he
doesn't know if he has to use it yet but
back to the americans having to ask
colombia for approval to build their
canal sure enough they show up and
colombia is like no go home
you guys are way too aggressive around
here lately we're not interested no
canal see you later so the u.s goes to
philippe and they say sorry bro the deal
is off columbia said no we said we'd
only do this if colombia said yes after
all panama is a part of colombia and
felipe is like wait hold on i have a
plan for this i've been talking to the
panamanians and they want to break away
from colombia and they made me their
ambassador i've even written them a new
constitution and designed them a new
flag wait philippe are you a graphic
designer no but i designed them a flag
anyway we can still make this canal
thing happen all i need you guys to do
is show up with your navy to make sure
that the panamanians can rise up for
independence without colombia coming to
shut it all down and the us congress is
like dude you're nuts see you later but
out of nowhere the president at the time
shows up and is like did somebody say
stage a theatrical revolution to take
over more land and increase american
power teddy was back on the scene teddy
loves this kind of stuff he loves the
sort of like backroom deals let's like
not ask for permission let's ask for
forgiveness this is like teddy
roosevelt's like sweet spot so felipe
has all of his ducks in a row he's got
teddy roosevelt on his side he has
panamanians who just gave him approval
to be their ambassador and he's like
let's do this so in november 1903
philippe gives the nod to the
panamanians to rise up to take over and
declare themselves independent and at
the same time he signals to teddy
roosevelt to send in their big gun boats
to sit off the coast of panama to block
colombia from sending in reinforcements
to put down this revolution by the
panamanians and so colombia is like oh
fine take it fu america you guys played
real dirty there okay you know that that
was not cool so just as felipe
orchestrated panama declares
independence and philippe is the
ambassador the us is the first to
recognize them as a new country and
teddy roosevelt's like that was
thrilling now what felipe so felipe is
like let's make a deal america i'm the
official representative of panama now as
per my agreement with the panamanians so
let's write a treaty on behalf of panama
so he travels to the united states and
starts working on a treaty between the
united states and panama that would give
the usa rights and sovereignty over this
strip of land to build a canal i mean
this series of events is insane france
fails to build a canal so one french
dude an engineer tries to redeem the
whole thing by convincing the us to
change the location of their canal and
then creates a revolution and convinces
the u.s to help back that revolution so
that he a frenchman can be the
ambassador of the newly created country
of panama and make a deal with the us
whoa philippe he was like the one-man
band lobbyist who somehow like finagled
this whole situation so felipe and the
secretary of state of the united states
draw up this treaty it gives the u.s
total control over this strip of land
for them to build their canal no
panamanians were in the room when they
drafted this tree they gave no approval
of this this treaty was between the us
and panama but really it was between the
us and philippe the french engineer so
now the u.s military shows up to panama
to like claim this land that they now
see as theirs and the panamanians are
like dude wtf what are you doing here
and the us is like oh you signed a
treaty with us giving us all this land
and panama's like no we didn't and then
they're like oh wait light bulb philippe
that's why he wanted to be our
ambassador i get it man we got played by
philippe and they totally did so now the
u.s is setting up shop in panama to
start digging their canal
[Music]
the u.s picked up right where the french
left off using effectively the same
route that the french had dug during
their seven years of misery and speaking
of misery the us was able to learn from
the french's mistakes they started using
railways to truck out all the dirt so
that the mud wouldn't slide back into
the canal and they learned how to drain
the puddles of water so that it wasn't
like a haven for disease-infected
mosquitoes and most importantly they
didn't try the crackpot idea of trying
to dig a canal all the way down to sea
level they went with the much better
idea of digging the canal up high 26
meters above sea level and using clever
engineering to get ships up to that
level like i said said that one french
engineer and dilicep was like no one
asked you get out of here so after 10
years of construction and a visit by
teddy roosevelt who staged this amazing
photo shoot of him wearing a panamanian
hat sitting on one of the machines all
to boost morale to get this project done
after all of that the u.s completed this
dream of slicing a water route through
this 80 kilometer stretch of land
philippe at this point is back in france
probably exhausted from all of his
scheming but ultimately very pleased
that he was able to pull it off so the
canal is done and here's how it works
remember that the land looks like this
you have the pacific and atlantic oceans
here at sea level and then the interior
of the land being about 26 meters above
sea level so first they built a dam on
this river to create this giant lake so
that they have loads of water to work
with that's why we see those trees
sticking up from the water for why these
hilltops turned into islands then they
built these brilliant inventions called
locks the boat enters here at sea level
they enter into this chamber where there
is a gate that is holding the water from
the high up lake back it's locked but
once the boat is in this holding chamber
they let the water from higher up come
down making the boat flow up it takes
about eight minutes for the boat to rise
then they move into the next chamber
where they do this again and again until
by the end of it the boat has been
lifted up 26 meters above sea level they
then traverse the rest of this canal
going through the artificial lake and
snaking through until they get to the
other side where now they need to get
down to sea level and they go through
the same process but in reverse they
finally make it down to sea level and
they can exit onto now a different ocean
than when they started
[Music]
it's honestly an engineering marvel and
it reshaped the global economic
landscape making it easier and safer to
move goods and people around the world
and yeah the us was very serious about
controlling this little strip of land
this choke point that they had built if
you look at a map from the early or mid
1900s you're going to see that the
panama canal zone was always marked as a
sovereign part of the us controlling a
choke point like this gives you a strong
strategic advantage and the u.s knew
that but the world would finally decide
that big powers shouldn't actually be
able to swoop in and take over whatever
land they want
the wind of change is blowing half a
gale in the panama canal zone americans
had to defend themselves as students and
other rioters demanded an end of the 61
year old canal zone treaty with the
united states and the panamanians in the
1960s finally had enough and they're
like yeah this land is actually ours so
in the 60s and 70s the panamanians rose
up in protest against this u.s
occupation of the canal and through a
series of treaties they finally got it
back officially on the last day of the
millennium december 31 1999 they signed
the last treaty that returned
sovereignty to panama and then jimmy
carter gave a speech in spanish in este
occasion i mean he he tried like really
hard and i guess that matters so today
the panama canal belongs to panamanians
it still uses the innovative technology
from 100 years ago that allows this
canal to be built 26 meters above sea
level but for all of the engineering
innovation that's present here to me the
more incredible part of this story is
how this one frenchman orchestrated all
of this he played all the geopolitical
forces at the time just right he used
panamanian's thirst for independence and
the americans thirst for imperialism and
ocean power all to make his dream of
this canal happen oh and to secure his
financial return on the project what a
wild story thanks for watching